les gens qui disent qui seraient
possible d'avoir une requête
d'utilisation de l'Islam en Tchétchénie
ne comprennent pas notre vie notre
religion
la prise d'otage de Moscou à brutalement
ramené la Tchétchénie à la une de
l'actualité à cette occasion j'ai
remarqué qu'on voyait rarement de
tchétchène s'exprimer à la télévision et
encore plus rarement sinon jamais de
tchétchène invités sur les plateaux de
télévision j'ai donc décidé avec
Catherine Barma dans l'invité 1 pour
essayer de comprendre voici Oumar ramier
bonsoir vous êtes donc tchétchène je
crois que vous êtes le premier
tchétchène vous exprimez à la télévision
française j'espère que vous ne serez pas
le dernier
alors vous êtes Oumar Khan ministre de
la Santé tchétchène ministre en exil
bien sûr la Tchétchénie en deux mots
c'est un pays de 19000 km², 1,2 millions
d'habitants une république située dans
le Caucase et les habitants d'ailleurs
comme on le voit en vous regardant sont
de type caucasien donc c'est pas un
peuple arabe mais c'est un peuple qui a
été islamisé au 18e et 19e siècle et un
peuple qui est en lutte depuis toujours
contre l'impérialisme grand russe alors
avec la révolution bolchevik en 1917 les
tchétchène croient à leur heure venue et
il se lance dans une guerre de
libération qui durera jusqu'en 1924
année de leur défaite en 1944 Staline
les accuses de collaboration avec les
nazis et des portes la population de
cette chaîne entièrement en Asie
centrale et en Sibérie la République
tchétchène disparaît elle préconisé par
les Russes et d'ailleurs vous ou Marc
vous êtes né au Kirghistan en 1955 et
vous n'êtes revenus dans votre pays la
Tchétchénie avec les autres chicken
qu'en 1960 ou votre famille a retrouvé
le village de ses ancêtres voilà alors
vous quand vous êtes revenus dans ce
village un jour votre mère frôle la mort
parce qu'il fallait deux jours au
médecin pour se rendre dans ce village
et vous décidez de devenir médecin ce
que vous ferez puis chirurgien alors
quand elle signe prend le pouvoir en
Russie il dit au tchétchène prenait
autant de liberté que vous voulez
évidemment à ce moment-là les tchétchen
se déclarent indépendants puisqu'on leur
a dit de prendre toute la liberté qu'il
voulait cette attitude n'est pas durée
pourquoi à votre avis la Russie a repris
la main sur la Tchétchénie après 1991
je suis très content que vous ayez si
bien raconté l'histoire de la
Tchétchénie
en Europe il y a des gens qui
effectivement connaissent bien notre
histoire donc le sur le voir
politique
selon la l'idée politique de Delphine
il avait on a toujours cru les mots des
politiciens russes
et c'est là que la guerre a commencé
alors vous à l'époque vous êtes chef de
l'hôpital militaire et un an après en 95
ministre de la Santé vous serez confirmé
dans ce poste en 1997 quand Aslan
maskadov était lu démocratiquement
président de la République tchétchène et
là il y a une période assez heureuse qui
dure pas longtemps qui dure peut-être
deux ans au cours de laquelle entre 97
et 99 les tchétchène reconstruisent leur
République
c'était en fait une guerre cachée
en fait travailler là les Forces
Spéciales pendant ce temps là
préparation du côté de la Russie du
nouvelle guerre
plus préparé avec plus de propagande
et un caractère de force plus importante
cette guerre a commencé seulement je
voudrais simplement connaître son
sentiment sur cette attitude des Russes
pourquoi les Russes ont vis-à-vis de la
Tchétchénie cette politique de douche
froide a laissé croire que le pays va
être indépendant à jouer au chat et à la
souris comme ça à rendre tant de gens
malheureux à leur donner un espoir qui
finalement va être assommé d'un coup de
marteau
quelle est votre sentiment là-dessus
pourquoi
cette tentative historique dans ses
actions
avec une période de paix puis de nouveau
la guerre
on voit que la Russie ne veut pas
quitter ses mauvaises méthodes et
utiliser une méthode Pacifique pour
résoudre des problèmes faut dire aussi
que que la Russie pompe à la Tchétchénie
chaque année 29 millions de tonnes de
pétrole un détail et il y a aussi des
oléoducs qui viennent de la mer
Caspienne qui traverse la Tchétchénie
donc tout ça est très important ce qui
fait dire à Oumar ramiv les Russes
veulent bien de la Tchétchénie mais ils
ne veulent pas des tchétchène
et maintenant
et aujourd'hui un grand intérêt se crée
avec la découverte dans le bassin de la
Caspienne de grande réserve de pétrole
donc cette question va se
s'exercerait
que que ce qui nous raconte là donne
raison à une de mes chansons qui
s'appelle le monsieur qui vend des
canons et où j'explique que c'est une
fois où les vandarmes ou le pétrole mais
que il décide qu'ils veulent au nom du
fric leurs intérêts
alors en octobre 99 donc tout recommence
un an plus tard c'est le siège de gosni
et la chute de grossesnil la capitale de
la Tchétchénie encerclé par l'armée
russe vous vous êtes arrêté en quittant
la ville avec un groupe de médecins et
de blessés vous êtes emmené en prison
vos muscles sont brisés à cause des
coûts que vous recevez certains sont
nécrosés et désormais vous avez beaucoup
de mal à opérer au Maran def comme avant
non et maintenant absolument donc cette
seconde guerre en Tchétchénie et d'une
violence inouïe d'une cruauté incroyable
des obus à Aiguillon des bombes à billes
qui font des dégâts invisibles à l’œil
nu donc on croit que la personne est
normale puis après on s'aperçoit qu'elle
a à l'intérieur du corps plein
d'aiguillons ou de petites billes des
bombes à effet de pénétration qui sont
interdites donc par la Convention de
Genève qui brise les eaux en mille
morceaux et desarticules les corps et
ensuite vous raconter ou marrante que
les que les prisonniers étaient battus
sur leur plaie et sur leur moignons
voilà la cruauté avec laquelle les
tchétchètes sont traités par l'armée
russe ensuite évidemment bon la
Tchétchénie est occupée par l'armée
russe les soldats russes sont bien
entendu harceler c'est ce qu'on appelle
une sale guerre l'opinion mondiale
s'intéresse au tchétchène et s'élève
contre l'anéantissement d'un peuple tout
entier
mais il faut dire les choses depuis le
11 septembre
2001 la Tchétchénie a été un petit peu
oubliée puisque la lutte de Moscou
contre les tchétchène a été assimilée à
la lutte antiterroriste ce qui fait que
la pression n'a cessé de la suppression
de la cessé de monter et la semaine
dernière nous avons vu cette prise
d'otage à ou un commando de 50 tchétchen
a retenu en otage 700 spectateurs d'un
théâtre en menaçant de tout faire sauter
si la guerre ne s'arrête pas
on connaît la suite est-ce que
Oumar and BF vous approuvez les méthodes
de ce commandement
a toujours dit et nous a toujours dit
que les méthodes des brigands ne sont
pas les nôtres que nous ne devons pas
suivre les pas de ceux qui exterminent
nos populations civiles est-ce que le
président maskadov était au courant de
l'opération du théâtre de Moscou
master
ne savait absolument rien de cela vous
savez que les Russes à Moscou ont fait
entendre une conversation entre mascadov
et des gens au Moyen-Orient au Qatar
est-ce que vous pensez que c'est une
fausse preuve ou est-ce que vous pensez
que le président était au courant et
qu'il ne vous l'aurait pas dit et qu'il
l'aurait pas avoué
le président et je connais suffisamment
bien pour ne pas y croire
ça fait déjà très longtemps
que on essaie de présenter notre
président comme un terroriste donc
il y a une situation qui se présente que
soit le Keita ou autre chose on essaie
toujours il faut essayer de chercher des
raisons
donc il n'y a pas de lien entre
mascadov et Al-Qaïda
que le que le la religion
l'islamisme de cette chaîne et un
islamisme suffit beaucoup plus modérée
que l'islamisme qui qui règne au
Moyen-Orient
les gens qui disent qui seraient
possible d'avoir une rockabillisation de
l'Islam en Tchétchénie ne comprennent
pas notre vie notre religion alors les
mystères du président
maskadov à Copenhague armées Zakaiev a
été arrêté mardi à Copenhague les Russes
demandent de son extradition
est-ce que vous pensez qu'il peut être
extradé du Danemark vers la Russie il y
a un gosse cette opinion n'est pas exclu
je ne peux pas répondre mais ce serait
une très grosse erreur de faire cela
est-ce que vous
vous êtes inquiet pour votre sécurité
donc pour ma vie j'ai je me suis fatigué
de m'inquiéter
alors le président Poutine est très dur
avec les tchétchène il faut rappeler
qu'il a fait ses classes au KGB donc
c'est quand même pas une école de grande
tolérance il a déclaré en parlant des
tchétchène il faut les buter jusque dans
les chiottes est-ce que aujourd'hui
après ce qui s'est passé à Moscou la
semaine dernière est-ce que vous pensez
qu'il y a encore des possibilités de
négociation ou est-ce qu'on est entré
dans une crise insoluble et d'un
changement à l'intérieur de la
Tchétchénie et en situation
donc on voit que la Russie continue à
exterminer
en Tchétchénie et c'est quelque chose
qui est
inutile qui est qui ne sert à rien
de
vraies autres que il faut pas aller dans
ce sens-là
et si vraiment la Russie veut sortir de
cette situation alors la seule solution
ce sont les négociations et bien sûr un
compromis serait possible là merci Oumar
Rennes et pour être sûr de ne rien rater
de innarditude abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu